merci beaucoup
sommes-nous seuls dans l'univers
il est vraiment seul c'est quand même
une méchante bonne question pour un
samedi matin
sommes nous seuls dans l'univers quand
on regarde la notre galaxie la voie
lactée
vous voyez si une très belle image de la
voie lactée qui est en train de passer
devant nous on voit des millions des
milliards d'étoilés en fait à l'oeil nu
on en voit juste quelques milliers mais
lorsqu'on pointe nos télescopes on
s'aperçoit que notre galaxie possède
énormément des toiles alors pourquoi
toutes ces étoiles ne posséderait t'elle
pas aussi de planètes autour d'elle
pourquoi serions nous les seuls autour
du soleil à posséder de la vie d'accord
et bien en 1995 enfin disons avant 1995
on connaissait très peu de choses en
fait des planètes on connaissait neuf
planètes d'accord bon maintenant on va
dire que on est rendu à huit planètes et
que on a rétrogradé la planète pluton au
sein des planètes net donc disons que on
connaissait simplement huit planètes
avant 1995
on connaissait des théories qui nous
disait qu'il y avait possiblement
l'existence d'exoplanètes des planètes
qui tournent autour d'une étoile autre
que le soleil et mais on n'avait pas de
preuves concrètes de tout cela il a
fallu attendre 1995 et les efforts de
nombreux chercheurs pour enfin arriver à
prouver hors de tout doute qu'il y
existait des exoplanètes et c'est cet
homme là avec son équipe michel mayor un
suisse un professeur à l'université de
genève et à l'observatoire de genève qui
a réussi à démontrer hors de tout doute
qu'il y existait effectivement des
exoplanètes autour des toiles autre que
notre système solaire donc la
probabilité pour que nous soyons seul
venait de diminuer
et comment at-il fait ça il a utilisé la
lumière l'outil je dirais préféré de
l'astronome
en fait on pourrait dire que c'est
quasiment le seul outil de l'astronome
même si on vient de découvrir des ondes
gravitationnelles la lumière c'est la
référence par excellence pour les
astrophysiciens et comment est ce que
l'on fait ça on regarde la lumière des
étoiles et on essaye de disperser la
lumière parce que la lumière blanche
contient énormément d'informations en
utilisant un prisme par exemple qui va
venir décomposer les lumières suivant
toutes ces longueurs d'onde du bleu
jusqu'au rouge
et lorsque l'on regarde une étoile
chaque étoile à une signature propre à
des éléments qui la composent du calcium
de l'oxygène et cetera
et lorsqu'on observe ce spectre de
lumière cette cette couleur de lumière
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya certaines ray
d'absorption qui sont dus en fait à
l'absorption des atomes dans les toiles
et ça va venir caractériser les toits
lui de ça nous permet de trouver samassa
température et cetera
lorsqu'une étoile ne possède pas de
planète
ce spectre reste fixe mais l'ours d'une
planète accompagne une étoile les deux
rentrent dans une sorte de danse qui va
venir faire osciller en fait ce spectre
là et ces oscillations sont la preuve de
l'existence d'une exoplanète autour
d'une étoile et c'est ce que monsieur
michel mayor et son collègue didier
queloz ont réussi à trouver alors cette
méthode là qu'on appelle la méthode des
vitesses radiales permet d'accéder
directement à la masse de l'exoplanète
en 99 et voici les voici
l'exoplanète que ce monsieur là à
trouver une exoplanète somme toute
similaire à la planète jupiter mais avec
la caractéristique caractéristiques
pardon qu'elle était très proche de son
étoile et tournées simplement autour de
sa planète de son étoile en quatre jours
à peu près donc bien différent de la
période de révolution de la terre 2
d'une année en 1999 david charbonneau un
canadien qui faisait ses études à
harvard de son pillage dit à lavardens
dr à harvard lui a trouvé notre méthode
qui a permis de trouver d'autres
exoplanètes
il a simplement regarder toujours la
lumière des étoiles mais il s'est aperçu
que lorsque les planètes passer devant
les étoiles la luminosité de la lumière
de l'étoile diminué donc la planète
passe devant l'étoile la luminosité
diminue et ça lui a permis de découvrir
par cette méthode là qu'on appelle la
méthode du transit où les méthodes d
éclipse de trouver de nouvelles
exoplanètes et cette méthode a été
utilisée pour construire un télescope
qu'on appelle le télescope kepler qui
maintenant on est à plus de 1000
planètes découvertes par cette méthode
la halle avantages de cette méthode là
et voici la planète qui l'a découverte
qui porte le doux nom de hd 20 94 58 b
on l'a rebaptisé depuis on l'appelle
osiris parce qu'elle est très très
proche de son étoile elle est très très
la température est très élevée et elle
est en train de perdre son atmosphère
cette méthode là en fait est très
intéressante parce qu'elle permet
d'avoir un accès direct au rayon de la
planète plus la planète est grosse et
qu'elle passe devant son étoile
plus la luminosité en fait de l'étoile
que l'on observe va diminuer et donc je
vais connaître le rayon donc la méthode
des vitesses radiales me donne accès à
la masse la méthode de la des transits
me donne accès aux rayons le problème
dans tout ça le problème entre
guillemets c'est qu'une ce ne sont que
des méthodes indirectes
on ne voit pas directement l'exoplanète
on mesure ses effets gravitationnels
avec la vitesse des vitesses radiales où
ces méthodes sur la luminosité de
l'étoile avec cette méthode du transit
il faut essayer de trouver de voir ces
étoiles et c'est ce qu'on fait en fait
trois chercheurs de l'université de
montréal en 2008 ils ont été les
premiers à photographier une exoplanète
est à prendre une image d'exoplanètes
ça reste quand même très difficile
pourquoi voici l'image d'une étoile à
travers un télescope
c'est très très compliqué c'est bon la
lumière d'une étoile vient nous
illuminer très fortement un peu comme
les spots qui sont aussi m'empêche de
vous voir d'accord ou comme par exemple
si c'est comme si je devais chercher par
exemple une luciole à côté d'une un
phare en étant très très loin le phare
bloque toute la lumière je ne serais pas
capable de voir la luciole alors comment
faire pour avoir la lumière des
exoplanètes et bien simplement on essaye
de cacher la lumière de l'étoile et en
cachant la lumière des étoiles on va
faire apparaître la planète qui se
trouve à côté de l'étoile
alors on peut le faire de deux façons
soit en mettant directement un masque
devant le télescope c'est ce qu'on
appelle un coronographe ou alors en
utilisant des méthodes un peu plus
poussé avec des calculs numérique très
très sophistiquée des algorithmes très
poussé qui nous permettent d'obtenir ces
images-là et l'exploit de ces trois
chercheurs la de l'université de
montréal qui sont rené doyon david
lafrenière et christian marois en 2008
c'est qu'il était parti pour observer
une exoplanète autour d'une étoile et
ils en ont trouvé
3 c'est l'image que vous voyez à gauche
ici c'est l'image du premier systèmes
extra-solaires fait par l'homme
vous avez au centre les toiles
multicolores qui résulte en fait des
différents traitements et d'algorithmes
qu'on a fait et vous avez des petits
points b c et d qui représente en fait
les trois planètes
en fait si on s'en apercevra plus tard
lorsqu'on frappe plusieurs calculs qu'il
y a plus que trois planètes y en a même
une quatrième qui est caché a beaucoup
plus près de l'étoile
mais vous avez ici trois planètes qui
tournent autour d'une étoile et c'est la
première image d'un systèmes
extra-solaires autour d'une étoile au
jour d'aujourd'hui au en date du 2 avril
il y actuellement 2099 exoplanète qui
ont été confirmés et qui sont tout aussi
varié on a affaire à une sorte de 2 ou
des exoplanètes où vous avez des
exoplanètes qui sont aussi grosse que la
planète jupiter jusqu'à des exoplanètes
qui sont à peu près de la taille de la
terre
le problème c'est que trouver des exo
planètes comme la terre
c'est relativement difficile parce que
plus elles sont petites et plus ça
devient compliqué de les voir d'accord
ou de voir leurs effets gravitationnels
alors que recherche-t-on quand on fait
de la science et quand on veut voir
essayer de de trouver de la vie à
l'extérieur du système solaire eh bien
on va appliquer ce qu'on appelle un prêt
le principe de médiocrité c'est pas du
tout péjoratif
ça veut pas dire qu'on est mauvais ça
veut dire simplement qu'on va chercher
quelque chose qui nous ressemble parce
que c'est la limite de nos connaissances
pour le moment on va chercher on va se
donner des outils pour trouver quelque
chose qui nous ressemble et cette chose
là ça va être une planète rocheuse qui
va posséder une atmosphère est la chose
la plus importante qui va être capable
d'avoir une couche d'eau liquide à sa
surface
et pourquoi est ce que l'on veut faire
ça parce qu'on veut trouver de la vie
mais on veut
pardon pourquoi est-ce donc vers ça et
comment on va faire ça en fait on va
utiliser des instruments que l'on est en
train de construire qui utilisent les
méthodes que je vous ai montré juste
avant la méthode des vitesses radiales
on va utiliser un instrument ici qui
s'appelle spirou et nice deux
instruments en fait qui vont être qu un
qui va être installé en 2017 au
télescope canada-france-hawaii spirou et
l'autre nous ce qui va être installé en
2019 à au chili et ces deux instruments
là vont être capables de trouver un
certain nombre beaucoup beaucoup ont
fait beaucoup de l'exoplanète par la
méthode des vitesses radiales on va
utiliser aussi la méthode de david
charbonneau et on va améliorer le
télescope kepler qui est simplement
capable de regarder dans une direction
avec un autre télescope qui s'appelle le
télescope paix ce qui lui va observer
tout le ciel avec ces deux méthodes la
méthode de la vitesse radiale et la
méthode du transit
on va être capable d'obtenir un maximum
de d'objets célestes qui correspondront
à des exoplanètes et on va être capable
de connaître leur masse et leurs rayons
si je connais leur masse et leurs rayons
je vais être capable de dire ce sont des
exoplanètes qui sont rocheuses ou pas
hein parce que en connaissant la malle
c'est le rayon je vais capable d'être
capable de déterminer là
en cité de ces exoplanètes là et si la
densité très élevée
je vais avoir à faire à quelque chose de
très lourd dont des exo planètes
rocheuses et si elle est très très
faible
je vais avoir à ce moment là faire à des
exoplanètes qui sont plutôt gazeuse est
plutôt grosses comme jupiter
qu'est-ce que je une fois que je vais
avoir sélectionné mais exoplanètes
une fois que j'aurai trouvé mais il
exoplanète rocheuse avec mon atmosphère
avec avec l'eau sa surface
on espère il va falloir que je trouve la
vie mais ça veut dire quoi la vie ça
veut dire recherché quoi exactement est
ce que c'est simplement rechercher des
bactéries des organismes
multicellulaires des animaux des plantes
ou même peut-être une forme de vie
intelligente
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas ce que
c'est que la vie hein
en fait c'est pas vrai on sait
exactement ce que c'est que la vie on
sait on sait ce qu'on va vouloir
chercher pour trouver la vie est ce que
l'on vouloir chercher pour trouver la
vie ça va être ceux ci des traces de
signatures biologiques parce que
l'inconvénient c'est qu'on observe que
des choses qui sont très très loin et on
sait à peu près tout pour le moment ce
qu'on sera capable de faire alors on va
être capable on va chercher quoi on va
chercher des signatures de l'ozone des
signatures de l'oxygène des signatures
du dioxyde de carbone qui pourrait être
par exemple un traceur de la
photosynthèse mais aussi un traceur de
l'activité biologique humaine par
exemple l'industrialisation ou
simplement la respiration des hommes on
peut chercher aussi le méthane le
méthane c'était un bon indicateur de
de l'activité en fait biologique animal
sur une planète
les fameuses vaches qui pète dont on a
entendu parler récemment ce sont les le
dégagement de méthane des animaux c'est
une source de méthane importante qui
vient polluer l'atmosphère d'une planète
et qu'on sera capable de retrouver et
aussi ce que l'on cherche principalement
aussi c'est la trace de l'eau la
signature idéal qui prouve que
l'exoplanète pourrait être habitable
comment on va faire cela
et bien simplement on va regarder
tranquillement passer à une exoplanète
devant son étoile et on va analyser la
lumière et la décomposer suivant les
couleurs c'est simple à dire mais c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué à faire la
lumière de l'étoile
il va falloir l'analyser trouver ensuite
la lumière de l'étoile et de
l'exoplanète avec la lumière qui passe à
travers son atmosphère et faire la
soustraction des deux qui va nous amener
à découvrir en fait ici vous avez un
spectre de lumière le côté à gauche
c'est le côté bleu de la lumière le côté
droit c'est le côté rouge et en
regardant donc ce spectre de lumière là
on va être capable de voir les
signatures des éléments qui sont
importants et qui constitue en fait
probablement la vie et l'on voit donc
ici dans ce spectre la présence d'âge le
zoo de l'eau de l'oxygène du ch cadre du
méthane et c'est donc c'est ça qu'on va
chercher à faire et comment est ce que
l'on va faire ça eh bien on va le faire
grâce un télescope tout à fait
exceptionnelle qui va être lancée en
2018 c'est ce qu'on a traditionnellement
l'habitude d'appeler le successeur du
télescope hubble
en fait c'est le successeur parce que
cette les scop qui vient après mais ces
caractéristiques sont quand même
différente puisque apple observée plus
tôt dans le domaine du visible celui ci
a observé du côté très rouge de la
lumière d'accord et c'est un se
télescopent là tout à fait
exceptionnelle possède quatre
instruments et de ses quatre instruments
il ya un instrument ici qui est fait au
canada et dont rené doyon celui qui a
découvert le système qui a pris la
première image du système exo planétaire
dont cet homme ce chercheur et le
chercheur principal de cet instrument là
qu'on appelle m
snif et cet instrument là est dédiée
principalement à l'étude de l'atmosphère
des exoplanètes et c'est avec lui avec
ce télescope là qu'on va être capable
d'analyser l'atmosphère des exoplanètes
et de trouver peut-être des signatures
des bio signature de la vie mais ce
n'est pas la seule chose en fait peu
l'on va faire ça c'est un télescope donc
le télescope james webb va être lancée
en 2010 8 en octobre 2018 le canada
s'implique aussi dans la construction
d'un énorme télescope un télescope de 30
mètres et se télescopent là aura pour
mission
quelques années plus tard après
l'apparition du télescope spatial hubble
de faire le suivi des planètes que l'on
aura découvert et qu'on aura analysé
pour essayer de prendre des images et
pour essayer d'étudier et de vérifier
que la vie existe bien sûr ces
exoplanètes là enfin choses complètement
folles dans 15 ou 20 ans on voudrait
essayer d'obtenir des images très
précises des exoplanètes qui seront
comme la terre avec leur atmosphère d
exo planètes rocheuses très très petit
pour ça on pense envoyer en fait un
télescope qu'on appelle le star chaîne
le télescope un télescope qui possède un
écran de 30 mètres de diamètre qui va se
déployer dans l'espace et qui va être
envoyée cet écran là à 50000 km du
télescope vont venir bloquer et faire la
méthode de david charbonneau venir
bloquer faire de la coronographie de
bloquer la lumière de l'étoile pour
pouvoir laisser juste apparaître les
exoplanètes et prendre des images des
exo planètes de type terrestre
une chose qui serait totalement
incroyable alors je vous laisse sur
cette avancée futur de l'astronomie et
du futur de l'astronomie en vous disant
que dans quelques années peut-être si
jamais en fait on est capable de
transcender et de trouver de nouveaux
systèmes qui nous permette de voiliers
13 très rapidement on sera capable
probablement de voyager et d'aller
visiter ces exoplanètes l'a d'ailleurs
la nasa a déjà préparé les affiches et a
déjà préparé son bureau de voyage
et je vous conseille d'aller voir sur le
site de la nasa pour admirer toutes les
propositions de voyage humoristique qui
sont qui sont faites
voilà merci beaucoup